[Music]
imagine what it would be like to have a
miniature version of our son right here
on earth with this artificial star
provide us with an infinite supply of
clean energy would we even need the coal
and nuclear power plants that give us
electricity today could the energy from
a mini Sun replace rocket fuel and could
we control it this is what if and here's
what would happen if we built a replica
of the Sun on earth the Sun is an
enormous nuclear fusion generator every
second it fuses 620 million tons of
hydrogen into 606 million tons of helium
in its core releasing a vast amount of
energy in the process to create a
replica of the Sun on earth we just need
to squeeze atoms of hydrogen hard enough
to make them fuse shouldn't be too hard
right
well this fusion is only possible at
extreme temperatures even the sun's
coldest part its surface burns at an
incredible 5,500 degrees not even a
spacesuit can protect you from that kind
of heat but we could engineer a high
temperature superconductor to tame our
scorching mini Sun what would it take to
bring this brighter future into reality
having an artificial Sun on our hands
would provide us with almost limitless
amounts of energy of course it would be
much smaller than the Sun our replica
could fit inside a machine the size of
60 football fields and would have the
weight of three Eiffel Towers to make it
work we'd need to specific hydrogen
isotopes one of them called deuterium
we'd extract from water the other one
tritium we brew from lithium during the
fusion reaction itself we'd give the
mini Sun its own magnetic field with the
help of huge magnets at least a thousand
times more powerful than those you put
on your fridge this field would keep the
artificial Sun in place while we're
heating it up to a hundred and fifty
million degrees few materials could
handle the scorching plasma of our Sun
we'd have to create a robust blanket for
it one that wouldn't melt during the
scorching fusion once we had all the
engineering issues figured out the
artificial Sun would complete
changed the way our energy system works
it wouldn't emit any greenhouse gasses
and there would be no hazardous
radioactive waste left to decay slowly
over a thousand years unlike fossil
fuels we'd never run out of hydrogen the
most common element in the universe with
this clean and safe source of energy
we'd stop adding fuel to climate change
and maybe give our planet a second
chance next we'd build fusion engines
for our spacecraft and go on to explore
space faster than we ever imagined with
hot plasma fueling up our Rockets it
would take us just 30 days to get to
Mars huge progress compared to a
nine-month trip with our current
technology sound like science fiction
what if I told you physicists around the
world have been working on recreating a
miniature star for decades we already
have reactors capable of producing
sun-like fusion but so far none of them
have produced more energy than they
needed to consume to make this reaction
happen in the first place everything
could change with a new class of
high-temperature superconductors that
would bring nuclear fusion from an
expensive science experiment to a viable
source of energy available to everyone
by the time scientists figure it out we
may have moved off earth and on to the
nearest planet but that's a story for
another what if
[Music]